dice multiplica 23 por 44 y tal vez tú
digas bueno ese punto es un signo de
multiplicación si de hecho si lo es ese
punto significa multiplicar es simple
notación es lo mismo que 23 por 44
escrito de esta manera o entre
paréntesis y también esto sería
multiplicar 23 por 44 todo es lo mismo
simplemente es notación y la voy a usar
la usual la usual sería poner el 23 aquí
arriba pongo 23 y 44 abajo después pongo
el signo de multiplicar que todo el
mundo conoce así ahora amd lo primero
que vamos a hacer es el 4 va a
multiplicar a cada uno de los dígitos en
el número 23 entonces primero vamos con
el primero 4 por 3 4 por 3
eso sería eso es igual a 12 cierto
entonces vamos primero con este pongo el
2 en el lugar de las unidades y llevamos
1 entonces pongo ese 1
arriba del 2 aquí ahora vamos con 4 por
2 eso es igual a 81 eso es igual a 9 y
lo que hicimos fue ok lo que hicimos fue
este 4 multiplicó a cada uno de los
dígitos en 23 4 por 23 es igual a 92
ahora vamos con el otro 4 baja entonces
mecánicamente lo que voy a hacer ahorita
en este momento es poner un cero abajo
del 2 aquí voy a poner un cero ahora
porque hago esto porque este 4 está en
el lugar de las decenas entonces estoy
multiplicando 4 por 23 otra vez serán 92
pero como está en un lugar de las
decenas esto es un 40 lo que estamos
haciendo es multiplicar 40 por 23 lo
cual será 920 por eso pongo ese ese 0
ahí entonces solo para dejarlo en claro
este 4 no es un 4 dado que está en el
lugar de las decenas es un 40 estamos
multiplicando 40 por 23 interesante no
entonces 4 por 3 es igual a 12 pongo el
2 aquí
1 el 1 lo voy a poner arriba del 2
entonces el 1 va acá arriba y nos
olvidamos de este 1 este uno lo
ignoramos ese 1 corresponde al otro 4
ahora 4 por 2 es igual a 8 más uno es
igual a 9 el 9 va aquí en el lugar de
las centenas perfecto entonces este 4
por 23 es igual a 92 y este 4 por 23 es
igual a 920 porque este 4 representa 40
está en el lugar de las decenas ahora 44
por 23 será 4 por 23 igual a 92 más 40
por 23 igual a 920 entonces lo que vamos
a hacer es sumar estos dos sumamos ya
sabemos que 2 + 0
eso es igual a 29 más dos es igual a 11
llevamos 19 más uno es igual a 10 por lo
tanto 23 por 44 es igual a 1012
y ya
terminamos